ya got in that car how did it drive
actually you didn't even have to drive
right exactly the car is able to handle
single lane highway driving autonomously
so all you have to do is basically to
press a button and the car can can break
I can accelerate and can handle stop and
go a highway traffic I think it's
especially helpful under heavy highway
traffic because that's really going to
relieve the stress from the drivers
Jimmu what is the technology behind this
car
right Nisa uses a monocular camera to
detect obstacles and it's working with
mobile I to the developer system to to
process the image the camera captures
it's very hard to say the technology is
grant breaking because a lot of features
are actually available on premium car
brands but it's still quite noteworthy
in the in the mass market segment
because this is still very nice in
technology nissan is I got reducing this
technology in the minivan called Serena
in Japan yeah and I gotta say you looked
a little bit hesitant to take your hands
off the wheel there look we've we've
heard about the fatality of Tesla and
it's auto pilot program how much of this
technology enables you the driver and
you personally when you drove it to feel
confident to let the car take over
yeah it actually needs undesigned a
hardware limitation that requires you to
actually put your hands on the steering
wheel if you if you take your hands off
the wheel is going to send you warnings
and if you keep ignoring those warnings
is eventually it will disable the
autonomous driving function Nissan will
make sure its dealers to inform the
consumers of this technote of these
autonomous driving limitations because
the whole point is is to is to let
consumers know that it's not a
driverless car it's not going to take
you from point A to point B is only
designed to to relieve the driving
stress